>> Juan: FRESHMAN
CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ FACING
CRITICISM AFTER SHE MADE
THIS COMPARISON.
>> THE UNITED STATES IS
RUNNING CONCENTRATION CAMPS
ON OUR SOUTHERN BORDER.
AND THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT
THEY ARE.
THEY ARE CONCENTRATION
CAMPS.
THE FACT THAT CONCENTRATION
CAMPS ARE NOW
INSTITUTIONALIZED PRACTICE
IN THE HOME OF THE FREE IS
EXTRAORDINARILY DISTURBING.
AND WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT IT.
>> Juan: AFTER
REPRESENTATIVE LIZ CHENEY
CRITICIZED THOSE REMARKS,
OCASIO-CORTEZ DOUBLED DOWN
TWEETING, QUOTE:  HEY,
REPRESENTATIVE CHENEY, SINCE
YOU'RE SO EAGER TO EDUCATE
ME, I'M CURIOUS, WHAT DO YOU
CALL BUILDING MASS CAMPS OF
PEOPLE BEING DETAINED
WITHOUT A TRIAL?
HOW WOULD YOU DRESS UP DHS'S
MASS SEPARATION OF CHILDREN
AT THE BORDER FROM THEIR
PARENTS?
DANA, I JUST THINK IT WAS A
POOR CHOICE, A POOR FRAMING
BY OCASIO-CORTEZ THAT
ALLOWED -- SHE SAID
SHRIEKING REPUBLICANS TO
BLOW BACK AT HER.
BUT, DO YOU THINK THAT SHE
HAS A POINT?
>> Dana: I THINK SHE LOST
THE BLOW BACK.
IT'S LIKE HER FUEL, RIGHT?
SO IT -- SHE DOESN'T CARE
WHAT SHE SAYS.
THAT WAS A FALSE AND
ALARMING -- IT WAS ALARMING
AND FALSE EQUIVALENT OF THE
UNPARALLELED EVILS OF WHAT
HAPPENED IN THE HOLOCAUST.
SHE SAYS NEVER AGAIN IN THE
ORIGINAL COMMENTS AND THEN
LATER SHE TRIES WELL, THAT'S
NOT WHAT I MEANT.
THAT CAN WORK FOR SOME
PEOPLE.
AND SOME PEOPLE WILL DEFEND
YOU WHEN YOU DO THAT.
BUT THERE IS NO -- THERE IS
LIKE THREE DEMOCRATS WHO ARE
DEFENDS HER.
I THINK THAT'S WHEN YOU KNOW
YOU ARE OUT THERE ON A LIMB
AND YOU ARE LIKE BUGS BUNNY
FALLING OFF THE END.
I THINK THAT PELOSI, AS A
SPEAKER, HAS A CHOICE TO
MAKE.
REMEMBER, THEY HAVE HAD THIS
SEVERAL TIMES.
ARE THEY GOING TO TRY TO GET
THESE YOUNGER MEMBERS IN
CHECK?
I DON'T THINK SO.
BECAUSE APARTMENT OC SHE
IS -- HER OWN PHENOMENON.
AND I DON'T THINK THEE MINDS
AT ALL CONTROVERSY.
SHE JUST LET'S IT ROLL RIGHT
OFF HER BACK.
SHE DOESN'T MIND WHAT SHE IS
SAYING A FALSE EQUIVALENT.
SHE DOESN'T CARE.
IT ACTUALLY FUELS HER.
>> Juan: ALL RIGHT.
LET ME GO TO THE MAGAZINE
EDITOR.
GREG, SHE SAYS SHE IS REALLY
REFERRING TO ESQUIRE ARTICLE
IN WHICH THE POLITICAL
ARTICLE SAID A CONCENTRATION
CAMP IS NOT A DEATH CAMP NOT
AUSCHWITZ OR WITH YOU
SEPARATE A GROUP OF PEOPLE.
>> Juan: PLAYING WITH WORDS.
HOW GREAT IS IT THAT SHE IS
REFERRING TO ESQUIRE
MAGAZINE FOR EXPERTISE ON
WHAT A CONCENTRATION CAMP IS
THAT'S CALLED THE MEDIA
LOOP.
SHE REFERS TO ESQUIRE AND
ESQUIRE REFERS BACK TO HER
AND SIT THERE IT'S A
SELF-REVERENTIAL MASSAGE.
WHO IS A QUESTION.
WHO IS A BIGGEST EXPERT ON
ANTI-SEMITISM?
AOC OR ISRAEL?
BECAUSE RIGHT NOW SHE IS
CREDIT SIZING TRUMP, RIGHT?
BASICALLY THAT'S WHAT SHE IS
DOING.
ISRAEL JUST NAMED A TOWN
AFTER TRUMP.
>> RIGHT?
I MEAN, IT'S NOT CORTEZ
HEIGHTS.
IT'S TRUMP HEIGHTS.
CASE CLOSED.
I MEAN, WHAT SHE DID, THIS
IS A MEASURE OF CHARACTER,
LOOK, SHE IS A BOMB THROWER.
TRUMP IS A BOMB THROWER.
SHE HAS A TALENT, BUT THE
FACT IS THE TALENT HAS TO BE
HOW TO DO IT CORRECTLY AND
SHE HAS GO TO OWN UP TO HER
MISTAKES.
SHE MADE A MISTAKE.
UNLESS SHE THINKS LIKE
CONCENTRATION CAMP MEANS
THINKING REALLY HARD, IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT AND BY THE
WAY, BURIED IN ALL OF THIS
IS SHE HAS NO SOLUTION FOR
THESE TEMPORARY ENCAMPMENTS
WHICH BY THE WAY OBAMA HAD
AS WELL AND USED THE SAME.
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A PLACE TO
PUT THESE PEOPLE THEN THEY
COME RIGHT.
IN YOU ARE BASICALLY SAYING
YOU ARE FOR NO BORDERS IF
YOU ARE AGAINST THE
TEMPORARY HOLDING.
AND IT'S SO MEAN TO THE
PEOPLE WHO WORK WITH THE
PEOPLE.
THE AGENTS.
I MEAN, ARE THEY
CONCENTRATION CAMP GUARDS?
IS THAT WHAT YOU ARE
INFERRING?
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE HER
APOLOGIZE.
SHE SHOULD PERSON UP.
>> Juan: EMILY, THE
PRESIDENT TWEETED OVERNIGHT
IN ADVANCE OF TODAY'S RALLY
THAT THERE IS GOING TO BE A
MASS DEPORTATION EFFORT LED
BY A LARGE NUMBER OF AGENTS
IN THE NEXT WEEK, APPARENTLY
ICE WAS SURPRISED BY.
THIS WE KNOW THAT KIRSTEN
GILLIBRAND AND RON I HAVE
TALL WERE THE FORMER ICE
DIRECTOR.
BOTH WERE RELUCTANT TO DO.
THIS THAT'S WHY THEY WERE
FORCED OUT.
HOW DOES THIS FIT IN TO WHAT
OCASIO-CORTEZ IS TALKING
ABOUT?
BECAUSE IT DOESN'T STILL
FARE IN THE IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITY.
>> Emily: I DON'T KNOW HOW
IT FITS IN OTHER THAN SHE IS
FAILING AT HER JOB WHICH IS
IF SHE HAS AN ISSUE WITH A
POLICY SHE INHERITED AS A
LAWMAKER.
GET OFF LIVESTREAM AND START
DRAFTING A BILL.
CHANGE THAT POLICY.
BECAUSE MY TAX DOLLARS ARE
PAYING YOUR SALARY AND YOU
SHOULD EARN THAT DOLLAR.
THE POLICY OF ICE AFTER
FINAL ORDER OF DEPORTATION
IS SUCH THAT WITHIN 90 DAYS
THEY INSTITUTE REMUFL
PROCEEDINGS.
AND, UNLESS THE SUBJECT
VOLUNTARILY, BASICALLY
LEAVES ON THEIR OWN.
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE NO DUTY
TO DO SO,IT IS ICE'S DUTY TO
COME WITHIN 90 DAYS AND
INSTITUTE THOSE REMOVALS.
AND BASICALLY GET A LETTER
IN THE MAIL AND IT SAYS MEET
HERE AT THIS TIME AND
SELF-SURRENDER WHY DON'T YOU
CHANGE IT AND GARNER SOME
TYPE OF COLLECTIVE COGENT
AGREEMENT ON THE HILL RATHER
THAN LOVING YOUR
LIVESTREAMING AND NOT
KNOWING WHAT YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT AND MAKING
INFLAMMATORY FALSE
EQUIVALENCY THAT ARE
HORRENDOUSLY OFFENSIVE?
>> Juan: BY THE WAY, JESSE.
EMILY MAKES A GOOD POINT.
I SAW IN THE POLLS 70 PLUS
AMERICANS THINK THE DREAMERS
SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO SAY.
60% SAY THE WAY WE CAN DEAL
WITH THE BORDER IS TO HAVE
MORE BORDER AGENTS.
MORE JUDGES.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> Jesse: I THINK 100% OF
AMERICANS DON'T AGREE WITH
AOC THAT WE'RE RUNNING
CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
>> Juan: I HOPE NOT.
>> Jesse: SHE IS BECOMING
MORE EXTREME BECAUSE SHE IS
RUNNING OUT OF STEAM.
SHE IS ONLY DOING THIS
BECAUSE SHE DOESN'T HAVE A
REAL SOLUTION.
ONLY THING SHE HAS OFFERED
SHE WANTS TO ABOLISH ICE,
SHE SAYS GLOBAL WARMING IS
PUSHING THE MIGRANTS NORTH
AND SHE SAYS WE ARE RUNNING
CONCENTRATION CAMPS.
SHE MEMBER OF CONGRESS WE
FORGET SOMETIMES BECAUSE SHE
SOUNDS LIKE A BOMB THROWER
ON CEANGET SHE CAN DO
SOMETHING.
SHE HASN'T SPONSORED ONE
PIECE OF LEGISLATION AT ALL.
AND NOW SHE IS BACKPEDALING
AND TRY TO DISTINGUISH
BETWEEN CONCENTRATION CAMP
VS. A DEATH CAMP.
SHE IS REALLY USING THIS
ISSUE.
SHE HAS DRAGGED HER PARTY SO
FAR TO THE LEFT ON
IMPEACHMENT.
ON GLOBAL WARMING AND ON THE
BORDER.
SOME OF THESE POSITIONS
NATIONALLY THAT SHE HAS
TAKEN TO ARE UNELECTABLE.
AND SHE HAS BEEN SPARRING
WITH PELOSI, HER BEST FRIEND
HAS BEEN ACCUSED OF
ANTI-SEMITISM.
YES, ON THE WHOLE, MAYBE SHE
OFFERS A LOT OF YOUTH
ENTHUSIASM, FUND RAISING,
FRESH GLAMOUR, PERHAPS.
BUT ON BALANCE, I DON'T
THINK SHE HAS BEEN
BENEFICIAL TOUT DEMOCRAT
PARTY.
>> Emily: GREG, TO YOUR
POINT, THE VICE PRESIDENT OF
THE NATIONAL BORDER PATROL
COUNCIL INVITED HER
PERSONALLY ART DEL GET
PERSONALLY ART DEL DET
PERSONALLY ART DEL DEL CUETO
SETS I WILL GIVE YOU A TOUR.
HERE
HEAR HER THOUGHTS AT THE
SAME TIME.